so I'm Alex from bite sized and I have
synesthesia and so I have grapheme to
color synesthesia which means that my
digits in my numbers have color and a
lot of times this is due to the actual
digits of the number themselves because
each digit from zero to nine has its own
color the colors of numbers above nine
actually have to do with their factors
as well and so things in the three six
nine series so multiples of three are
actually my warm colors so three is red
six is orange and nine is sort of the
very dark red maroon comes here with me
okay yeah absolutely zero is sort of a
clear number one is simultaneously white
and black two is green three is red four
is blue five is very black six is orange
seven is yellow eight is sort of a
darker blue nine is a very dark maroon
and then once you get into things like
ten they're simultaneously white and
black a lot of the two and three digit
numbers have to do with their actual
digits that things like 20 will be very
predominantly green because they start
with a two however that twenty is
actually a little bit more clear or
white and black as well because it has
the two times the ten which is
simultaneously white and black it also
has a little bit of the four thrown in
so it's a slight blue tinge as well as
sort of a little bit of that black from
the five so when you're telling me this
and you're like envisaging it what's
happening in your brain are you seeing
the number are you seeing the number
five that color are you just seeing a
color I'm actually seeing the number in
that color but I try and describe it to
people as the space in my brain that it
occupies is the same space that I would
occupy if you tried to visualize a
pumpkin right now because I said it to
you you don't see it in the world in
front of you but you see it in a space
in your head and so the numbers in my
head are that color so when you were
counting through the numbers for me a
minute ago we you like could I in your
in your mind's eye was there like a
white background and then there was a
number five of that color like like the
shape of the five or you just was your
mind's eye just going all that color
like a like a flash to color it is sort
of that number
in its color I think I've developed such
a strong visualization to them that now
the numbers and the colors are the same
almost so if I see something like four
red blocks on a table it's intrinsically
wrong to me because it should be either
four blue blocks or three red blocks it
doesn't cause me problems that it
absolutely interacts with the way that I
interact with my world so it helps with
how I visualize math problems and it
also sort of helps with how I look at
the world around me and classify things
and remember things does it make you
better I don't think it makes me better
at all I think it's something actually
that a lot of people have but they don't
realize that they have I didn't realize
that I was doing this until my freshman
year of college when a professor called
out you know does anyone in this
classroom see numbers with colors and my
first response is that stupid numbers
don't have colors they have
personalities and then I realized that
the personalities I was equated with my
numbers were their colors nine was a
very angry number because it was so dark
in red whereas twos and fours were much
happier numbers because there were cool
blues and greens when you've done a bit
of research and found out about other
people with this condition or scale
whatever we're going to call it did they
associate the same colors with numbers
was everyone different no absolutely not
that's the best thing that I found is
that sharing my numbers of colors is I
have the strong reaction from other
synesthetes to go no absolutely not
five is the brightest yell you've ever
seen and six is a dark blue and how dare
you have different numbers and I think
that's the best part of it is that
everyone interacts with these numbers
and colors in a very different way
thirteen most importantly his tremendous
good luck it's bad luck for everybody
else but for a magician someone who
likes crime what was the other thing
this is called not respecting your
favorite number well enough when I was
13 I decided that was silly and so the
last one stuck and so my favorite number
has always stuck at 27 well it's even
and as the lowest even number